this is a very classic Mexican style
brunch dish bold kick-ass flavors slice
the chili seeds in garlic sliced nice
and thin Li tablespoon of olive oil I'm
a big fan of brunches and if you get it
right a great brunch can see you right
through to dinner now to start the sort
of spicy fragrant tomato sauce get your
cumin in there garlic chili roasted
cumin red onions already sounds Mexican
once that starts getting really nice and
crispy in with you tomatoes never
embarrassed using good canned tomatoes I
do all the time cooking at home now I
reduced that sort of come down to a
delicious paste leave that to simmer
next can beans called black beans these
are authentically Mexican but cannellini
beans or chickpeas will work just fine
just rinse them little bit of water that
is beautiful turn off the gas and just
let it absorb leaving the dense beans to
luxuriate in the spicy tomato sauce will
allow them to soften and soak up all the
flavor next oil and season and oven
proof dish from my spicy egg brunch the
bacon I'll just get some of that oil
around the outside take your corn
tortillas slice them in half and then
just stick them to the side these are a
staple in Mexico
take one and place that in the center
get your mix and place that on top of
the tortilla spread that out nice and
smoothly lift up those little flaps
I want that crisp shell on the outside
now your eggs and cheese get the base of
the egg and just making a little hole in
there and then crack the egg into again
use a little point put your egg in there
one
two three four five and one in the
middle
gently crack and get the egg to sit
inside almost like you've little dug out
I'm in one for the center got a really
nice rich delicious strong Montgomery
cheddar on a great little tear shell as
well so get generous with it on the top
and they're season that with these
little babies little chili flakes
they're my little secret weapon and
they're gonna spice up that egg
just salt such a pepper sit that in the
oven to bake for 8 to 10 minutes and 180
[Music]
[Applause]
this smells incredible just a little bit
of coriander to finish off and that for
me is what brunch is all about let's go
a fantastic fiery brunch to get your
party started
spicy Mexican eggs in a crispy tortilla
shell